le variant delta a tout bousculé voire
chambouler les stratégies vaccinales des
différents pays à travers le monde selon
l' oms il a été identifié dans 85 pays
quelles solutions pour le contrer alors
qu'ils continuent de gagner du terrain
prenez l'exemple de l'islande qui fait
partie des pays les plus vacciner au
monde pourtant cet état insulaire de 370
milles habitants où près de 93 % des
plus de 16 ans sont vaccinés fait face à
une flambée des cas spectaculaires les
autorités remettent donc en question
leur stratégie vaccinale si une
troisième dose est souvent plébiscité
l'islande elle analyse la situation d'un
autre angle l'épidémiologiste en chef du
pays estime que la capacité des vaccins
à empêcher les infections des personnes
inoculé est bien trop faible selon lui
il faudrait laisser les gens se
contaminer naturellement afin d'obtenir
à terme une immunité collective en
israël allemagne royaume uni ou la suède
pays où les campagnes de vaccination
vont bon train est la troisième dose est
la solution ultime pour les plus
vulnérables
en france aussi le variant delta met à
mal la lutte anti qu'ovide et le
gouvernement veut vite passer à autre
chose sur les recommandations du conseil
scientifique le président emmanuel
macron continuent d'évoquer la nécessité
de cette fameuse troisième d'auzan très
chaud sur les réseaux sociaux et ce à la
rentrée il est maintenant établi que
pour lutter contre ce virus il faut des
rappels et il faudra vraisemblablement
une troisième dose pas pour tout le
monde tout de suite mais en tout cas
pour les plus fragiles et pour les plus
âgés nous le ferons à partir de la
rentrée pourtant la haute autorité de la
santé et l'agencé européenne des
médicaments prend le contre-pied de
cette préconisation du chef de l'état
selon lagence les données sont trop
insuffisante il est actuellement trop
tôt pour confirmer si et quand une dose
de rappel pour les vaccins kovy 19 sera
nécessaire car il n'y a pas encore assez
de données provenant des campagnes de
vaccination et des études en cours pour
comprendre combien de temps durera la
protection vaccinale à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé sa ligne sur cet
avis il est encore trop tôt pour
s'aventurer à administrer une troisième
dose le patron de l' oms estime qu'il
faut suspendre les dose de rappel mais
pour une raison précise certains pays
certaines régions sont en train de
commander des millions de dose de rappel
tandis que d'autres n'ont pas pu
vacciner leurs personnels soignants et
les parties les plus vulnérables de leur
population nous avons un besoin urgent
de renverser les choses d'une majorité
de vaccins allant dans les pays riches à
une majorité allant dans les pays
pauvres pour y arriver il nous faut la
coopération de tout le monde en
particulier la poignée de pays et
d'entreprises qui contrôlent la
production mondiale de vaccins mais
advienne que pourra
c'est la loi du plus fort les vaccins
ont été distribués à 80 % dans les pays
à revenu élevé ou moyens alors qu'ils
représentent moins de 50 % de la
population mondiale les pays les plus
pauvres n'ont pour le moment reçu qu'une
infime partie des sérums et bien ils
vont devoir encore attendre
israël et les états unis ont rejeté
l'appel de l'om estimant qu'il n'y avait
pas à choisir entre vacciner sa
population et partager son stock avec
les pays les plus pauvres ce sont les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques qui se
frotte les mains notamment le duo files
heures bio ntech qui plaide évidemment
pour ce rappel le géant américain et
l'entreprise allemande devrait découler
pour
33,5 milliards de dollars de vaccins en
2021 alors que l'om est ce prêche dans
le désert un organisations demandent un
moratoire jusqu'à septembre
selon elle l évolution de la pandémie
dépendra des éventuels décision des pays
du g20 dont le sommet est prévu en
octobre si les avis divergent l'islande
serait le premier pays occidental à ne
pas proposer la troisième dose et
defacto à suivre elle les
recommandations des organisations de
santé